[Music]
when at a charity soccer match yes that
you participate I was lucky enough to
participate in the UNICEF soccer aid
which took place at Old Trafford
Manchester United's Stadium 75,000 let's
talk in front of 75,000 people which
makes no sense why are you are you a
good soccer player I I am uh you know I
played a bunch growing up and I took
about a 15 year break and which is
recommended from all athletes that's how
the good ones do it yeah
and they kind of you know they kind of
convinced you that's gonna be like you
know rock and jock softball game just
run around hit the ball have some laughs
right but know everyone there has played
like semi semi professionally and they
take their soccer very seriously
I was on the rest of the world team it's
England versus rest of the world yeah
rest of the world rest of the world and
I and I badly I I pop my hams hamstring
yeah a badly hurt what badly hurt and I
had to limp I played for 70 minutes it
was pretty good but then it was 70
minutes and and then got my hamstring
and I had I literally had to hobble off
the field and after the game to walk the
length of the field to get you know into
the training room and you know I thought
the coach would be like I'm so sorry I
should taking you out because this is
you're just a your celebrity helping out
and and but he's he was the former coach
for Liverpool last year and his comment
to me was like hey well when I saw you
hobble and off the field I was I was
wondering if you're gonna audition for
one of your Hollywood cowboy movies
and it just had a huge laugh and just
walked away I don't know if I'm ever
gonna walk again yeah you really got
hurt we have we can talk over this you
can explain what's happening let's look
at this we see there's the play where
you're am you get hurt right there see
and you are seriously hurt and you can
tell you're in real pain and this being
one a massive stadium right and then I
have to sign autographs he's happy to do
happy to do but still 75,000 autographs
but I wish I was attempting a bicycle
kick or something but it was just I was
literally just trying to stop a ball
right right well you will you'd think
that that would have put an end to you
trying things you know in sporting
events but it didn't you to promote this
this new movie the campaign right you
and your co-star Zach Galifianakis yes
throughout each got to throw out a pitch
we've got we got a wriggly field we
threw out the dueling first pitches at
Wrigley Wrigley Field and uh it was uh
it was gonna be a thing where Zach
throws a pitch and then I throw a pitch
and the crowd judges to see who throws
the best and we thought it'd be funny if
we had a pizza delivered in between the
two pitches right it's it's sort of
funny but we thought it'd be weird at
least sure and just have a pizza for no
reason no reason but sure enough the the
public address announcer starts saying
ladies and gentlemen uh-oh looks like a
pizza is being delivered
so that looks like a bad promotional
many some delicious Gio don't know deep
dish is coming to the mouth and I
literally just started shaking my head
like I'm sorry people of wriggly
otherwise it was gonna be amazing
amazing piece of comedy but you are you
you got it you through it furnace in and
you thrown out you just threw out a
first I did that yeah a few weeks ago
yeah when we were out there well I get
to throw out a first pitch where he was
it exciting it was it was it was great
it was really fun it's pretty fun yeah
yeah they cheered in as much as only
probably 15% of those stands were paying
attention yes yeah we're involved in
passage obtaining yeah yeah yeah yeah
sausage obtaining yes that's what we
were fighting Wrigley has the most
sausage obtaining of any yes